the fans wanted to see it the
screenwriter was down for us so why
didn't tom cruise appear in dr strange
too keep watching to find out spoilers
for dr strange and the multiverse of
madness ahead while top tier cameo
killer wunder maximoff went to town on
some of marvel's most powerful figures
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness there was one supposed guest
appearance for which he never even
needed to break a sweat as much as some
corners of the internet ended up in a
frenzy theorizing that tom cruise would
step up as the illuminati variant of
tony stark in the latest doctor strange
film it apparently just wasn't meant to
be what could have become the new face
of stark industries was entirely absent
from the film no matter how many ultron
bots were on display
without me
you're nothing
in the lead up to the release of
multiverse of madness a number of fans
believe that a shot in an early trailer
of a super powered being squaring off
against the scarlet witch was actually a
character established in marvel comics
lore named superior iron man which is
effectively a version of tony that ends
up becoming a little power crazed of
course by now it's been confirmed that
the character in question was actually
leshana lynch as maria rambo who in that
universe is its captain marvel while
some marvel cinematic universe fans
might be disappointed with this
revelation it seems that according to
the film's writer michael waldron we
really only have ourselves to blame
speaking to rolling stone following the
release of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness waldron revealed
that tom cruise was on his wish list for
potential cameos and even went as far as
suggesting it to marvel studios head
kevin feige however this was something
that never came to pass in spite of the
frame by frame examination of trailer
footage that fans had determined to
tease the actor's arrival in the mcu
waldron told the magazine
yeah that was totally made up i mean
there's no cut footage of tom cruise but
i love tom cruise and i said to kevin at
one point i was like can we get tom
cruise's iron man i remember reading
about that in ain't it cool news back in
the day that tom cruise was going to be
iron man a link between cruz and marvel
even if not a part of doctor strange is
not entirely outside the confines of
reality however as waldron noted back in
the 90s the action star from mission
impossible was approached to take the
role of tony stark when the first
attempt at bringing iron man to the
silver screen was in its earliest stages
of production some crews as iron man of
course never came to pass and we instead
got the pitch perfect casting of robert
downey jr in the role instead which
clearly worked out pretty well in the
end nevertheless plenty of fans still
hold on to their hope of seeing this fun
twist on screen and in turn so did
waldron which is why he even attempted
to throw the name to feige waldron
admitted as it was being talked about
online i was like yeah that'd be cool of
course nowadays tom cruise's calendar is
pretty crammed with appearances in some
of his established temple franchises
this month cruz is returning to the
skies in top gun maverick which sees him
reprising the role of maverick mitchell
for the first time since 1986. after
that cruz is slated to once again steer
any high speed mode of transport he can
get his hands on in mission impossible
dead reckoning with parts 1 and 2 set
for release in 2023 and 2024
respectively as a result when asked if
cruz was ever given a call about
appearing in the mcu waldron revealed
that feige and marvel never even reached
out in the first place he said i don't
believe so i just don't think it was
ever an option because of availability
it's a shame that cruiser's casting
never came to pass but then again
there's a good chance it may have taken
the spotlight away from a handful of
other great appearances already in the
movie
maybe they're just here for me
also let's face it this is tom cruise
after all he wouldn't sign on to a
superhero film unless he could say
actually fly in a functional iron suit
or fighting a real scarlet witch
maybe next time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]